let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p here's a voicemail that came
in let's take a listen to it David why
don't you you didn't speak accurately on
this topic it was about astrology so
what you said you don't believe in
astrology but that's not the truth but
the truth is you don't know anything
about astrology do you you don't know
what the moon and other planets
positions are at birth means to a person
do you do you know what ascendant means
I doubt it
you don't know umm you confuse daily
horoscope crap with real astrology daily
horoscopes are entertainment for the
non-thinking
daily horoscopes are nothing more than
Chinese fortune cookies no you should
have said I know nothing about astrology
and I don't believe in it that would be
accurate right right I love this this is
the same argument that the gun
fetishists make they go do you even know
what AR stands for and some people will
say I think it started stands for
assault rifle they go no it doesn't you
have no right to talk about gun safety
legislation because you don't know
anything about what guns actually are it
doesn't matter whether I know what a
planet or whatever being ascendant is or
mercury being in retrograde or whatever
what I do know is the history of
astrology how it started really
astrology and astronomy sort of came
from the same source they split at a
certain point astronomy became actual
science which allows us to learn about
outer space planetary bodies and and
astrophysics and so much else but not so
much astrophysics actually but we could
argue that it sort of came from that an
astrology is a scam and I don't even
want to call it a pseudoscience it is a
non science there is no evidence
whatsoever that people's personalities
and daily lives are influenced by the
positions of planets at birth or whether
Mercury's in retrograde or whatever but
is it even worth wasting my time because
when you hear a voice mail from someone
like this it's like an anti-vaxxer it's
like a committed trumpet
it's like a committed gun fetishist is
it really worth wasting our time I think
the value of it is just in hearing that
these types of folks exist and they will
turn on you immediately as soon as you
don't tow the line we've got a great
bonus show coming up for you today we'll
talk about how the Pentagon plans to
spend some extra cash that they've got I
will tell you about a man who told a
woman that he had been poisoned and the
antidote was sex Wow and we will also
talk about an army vet who served two
tours of duty in Afghanistan and has now
been deported to Mexico get the bonus
show by becoming a member at david
pakman.com slash membership you can also
sign up at patreon.com slash david
pakman show make a $5 a month
contribution you'll also get instant
access to the bonus show